Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I'm your host, Rawkode. Today, we are
gonna be taking a look at project Velero,
a tool for Kubernetes to help make all
of our backup and restore lives a lot
easier. Now before we begin, there's just a
little bit of housekeeping I'd like to take
care of. First, please, if you're not subscribed
already to the YouTube channel,
subscribe now. Click the bell. This helps other
people find the content,
and it means you get really cool notifications
when more episodes are going live.
Also, if you are not watching live and
you're watching this later, you may have questions.
You may want to suggest new episodes or
technologies you'd like to see covered, or maybe
you just want to chat with other cloud
native and Kubernetes people. We have an active
Discord server with a few hundred people there.
Feel free to come and join us and
talk technology.
And lastly, I would love to thank Equinix
Medal, my employer. They allow me the time,
energy, resources to put this show together and
provide cloud native learning materials so we can
all learn together.
So if you wanna check out Equinix metal,
you can use the code Rawkode.
This is different from previously, so don't fall
for the trap. This now gets you 200
US dollars and credits that you can use
on the platform,
which you can use very, very quickly and
under fifty hours, or you can get up
to four hundred hours of compute with our
smallest instances. So feel free to check that
out and let me know how you get
on.
Alright. Now, with today, we're taking a look
at project Velero, and I am honored to
be joined by Carlisia Thompson, a engineer at
VMware, a maintainer of Velero.
Hi there. How are you?
Hi, David.
Thank you for having me on the show.
Hi, everybody.
It's
our pleasure to host you today. We're very
excited to take a look at Velero.
Do you wanna just start? Give us a
little bit of an introduction about yourself. Share
whatever you wish, and and we'll take it
from there.
Yeah. Sure thing. So I am an engineer.
I work for VMware.
I'm one of the Velero maintainers.
There are a few of us from VMware.
There is someone from Susie
Sousa,
and we always welcome
people who are interested in becoming maintainers,
just for the records.
What else? I am a CNCF ambassador.
I think
I'm very interested in what's going on with
the community. I try to help out when
I can.
I do I am a host of the
the Podlets
podcast,
which which
is a panel of hosts that talk about
cloud native technologies.
What else? I
think that's plenty.
Yeah. Like, what else? I mean, you listed
so much there. You must you must like
being busy.
I I like to say that I am
Brazilian because if in case people are wondering
where my accent comes from.
I do live in The US, though. So
in
California.
Well, thank you for sharing all of that
with us.
We're very excited for today. So why don't
we start off then a little bit about
what project Velero is?
Yeah. In fact, let's just start with that.
What what is project Velero?
Yes. Project Velero is an open source tool.
It's a CLI tool
that
you install on a Kubernetes cluster,
and you can run backups on that cluster.
And you can run backup,
complete back backups of a complete cluster,
or you can do selective backups. For example,
if you just wanna
back up a particular namespace,
you can schedule backups.
And then if, lo and behold, something happens,
you can pull the whatever backup you want
and restore it back in that cluster. You
can also install Velero in a different cluster
and restore
a backup on that cluster, which is sort
of like make doing a migration.
And it's I think it's it's very easy
to use given what it does.
It's very well supported. It's a very active
project.
It's been work worked on
for years,
and, it's it is sponsored by VMware.
And VMware is definitely making a lot of
investments
in it.
Yeah. That that's great to hear. I think,
you know, backup and restore is just
one of those things that a lot of
people may not think about upfront when they're
piling up their Kubernetes platform, but it's like
definitely something that you should always have a
strategy for because
disaster recovery is, you know, all well and
good until you need it and you need
it to work well. I think Velero is
fulfilling a very important
Yes. Requirement. I I yeah. I I think
so. I agree with that. And a lot
of people leave backup for last.
Let's say if you were
exploring
Kubernetes,
coming on board with Kubernetes,
you are thinking of so many different things,
and the last thing on your list is
backup. And I think it should be the
first thing because as you
tweak things around,
if you just had a backup to restore
everything back to where it was before,
it would be so much
easier.
So just having that,
feature alone, just be able to okay. Let
let's put everything back where it was because
we messed up something here as we are
learning.
You so even for that and Velero is
so easy to install and run. That's there
is no excuse. You should not be running
scripts.
Velero does all of that for you. So
Exactly. Let's let's say that the the clip
from today's episode should be every Kubernetes cluster
has Velero available. Like, it just I think
that should just be table stakes now, but
backup recovery is so important. Yeah.
And of course,
you know,
you also have to restore things regularly. And
I think some of the more high performing
teams that I've worked with or, you know,
even just speaking to a coupon and other
events are are teams that have got this
done to an art form as well. Been
able to I've seen one organisation,
don't know if I can say their name,
but maybe I'll tweet it later,
who actually
do almost immutable upgrades on their cluster by
using backup and restore to do the upgrades.
Like they don't do any in place upgrades.
They spin up new clusters and then restore
from the old cluster to the new one.
And I always thought that was almost a
superpower of theirs because
it just opens up so many different avenues
for that platform.
Does that make sense? Yeah. It makes Do
you see people doing that? Well,
there are so many different use cases.
For example,
the ability ability to just back up your
environment. Let's say, I'm the developer.
I'm doing something. I back up the environment,
and I say, hey. Restore this, and you're
going to have
this thing to run, which is exactly like
my thing. Right? And it could be
a developer sending things to,
people who to test
or for or for people to try out,
like, for the marketing department. I don't know.
There are so many different use cases that
you can use something like that for. Yeah.
Definitely. Yeah. I couldn't agree more.
And you said something there twice that I'm
just gonna bring up a third time and
hope that it doesn't jinx this, but you
said it is very easy to install and
I'm looking forward to my backup and I'm
looking forward to the easy installation of Velero
to my cluster. I have
prepared a really simple workload, but hopefully it's
visual enough that we can see
where Velero fits in, how the backup happens,
and then even trigger the restore bit.
So what I'm gonna do is
share my screen.
This is the Velero.i0
homepage. This will be where anyone at home
who wants to try this on their own
time should just start. We're gonna dive straight
into the documentation.
And, I mean, I always ask this question,
and then feel really silly afterwards. But I
guess the first step is for us to
install Velero. Is that right?
The
so the first step
is so the first step is you need
to provision the cluster. You have to have
the cluster. Yeah. I know it's for the
then I
probably thought about that. So you have to
have the cluster up and running.
There I I say that because there are
so many tools out there now. Sometimes you
might think of well, there are also pro
will provision things for you now. So you
you need to have that.
Then you have to go through the documentation
and find the provider
you are using or if you're using on
prem
and
find the documentation for the plug in that's
the corresponds to that provider. So do you
know which provider you I mean, you know
what which provider are you using?
It's a bare metal cluster on Equinix Metal.
Does that complicate things?
No. No. No. So in that case, you're
going to so because we need to connect
to a
an s three or s three comparable storage.
So in that case, we
we can use menu
unless you have looked ahead and have set
up some other storage.
I should have.
I do have
access to AWS.
I could really quickly create a bucket. I'm
assuming we would just need some really simple
credentials to get that running.
Yes. You you need the access key and
in in the bucket name. Yes. You also
said the other option there was Menio. Now
Menio has a pretty stable helm chart, which
we could throw into a namespace on the
cluster itself. Right? Because we're doing backup and
restore of individual namespace, I believe. So
Yes. So I just wanna say
something very important about alerts, red flags.
You don't wanna do that in production.
You don't wanna because you're backing up a
cluster,
and if your cluster and if that the
if that's where you have your
store the storage for your backups and the
cluster goes down, you don't you don't have
a way to restore it. Right?
So do not do that in production.
You wanna have
your
s three buckets
somewhere else other than in your cost environments.
Yeah. That's great great advice.
If we can keep that in mind, you
can, yeah, you can have Minio running anywhere.
I think I'll just grab a a Docker
command and stick it on a host. I'll
keep it outside the Kubernetes control plane. Just
because you're right, I shouldn't stick it there.
So I wouldn't use the helm chart, but
I can just run this on a machine.
We'll pretend that it's in a different data
or
somewhere else or it's very safe and secure
and
it'll be fine. Totally fine.
I'll just grab an IP address.
And
there we go.
Oh, very good point, actually.
I don't wanna install Docker, use containerd.
Trickier.
There's a binary. Right? Let me.
I should have looked ahead.
There we go.
Because, you know, in in my head, I
knew we needed an s three compatible object
store, but I just didn't think.
Why I also didn't think to ask you.
So that makes two of us. Yeah. Well,
we'll just grab this binary and
run it. And many of those really take
any setting up, so it'll be
fine. We'll make it executable.
Just run manual
server.
Think I a command here rather than me
just bashing on keys until it works.
Oh yeah. Okay. So, server and then just
the directory. Perfect.
Cool.
So menu admin and menu admin, I think
it's just the credentials we can use.
Yeah. We'll we'll just take it from there
and we'll see what happens.
What's the worst?
That looks good.
And now we have another terminal. Okay.
Slight segue done.
Hopefully, disaster averted. We have our s three
compatible storage. So
I have a Kubernetes cluster. I have a
workload. It has a persistent volume. It has
state, and I have something that works and
acts like s three.
So
our next step So
so with menu, the plug in that we're
going to use is the AWS
plug in.
Okay.
So
should I just go into this basic install
bit first?
So what I would do is go on
the search bar, Yep. Up up up on
the left. Search for menu.
Yes. That
the and and as a if if people
noticed, that page says evaluation.
This is not for production.
It's a it's a very good way to
set up if you wanna evaluate Velero.
Alright. So
I will do. I'm gonna open that. I'm
gonna turn to my right because I'm gonna
look at that. It's a bit too tiny
for me. Oh, sorry. I I should have
No. It's earlier. If you right click on
it and say show controls, you can fill
screen the video.
Oh. Yeah. I was so
annoying.
But, yeah, if you right click and show
control, should you'll be that'll make your life
a lot easier.
Yeah. Now we now we get it.
Okay. I'll just quickly brew install Velero and
get the CLI available to me locally.
Oh,
that reminds me.
If?
We just released the 1.6 version, and I
don't think we did the brew. We updated
the brew install.
Ah. Oh, no. It's there. There you go.
1.6. It is? Yeah. Somebody did it. Great.
Yeah. One sec, though, seems to be coming
through here. Yep. Yes. So that's what I
wanted to to use today.
Oh, yeah. This is the That's a just
not that. Still version. Right?
Okay. Alright. So let's see what we're looking
at here. What we're looking at here is
we have the client version,
and the error
is saying
you don't have Velero installed
anywhere where that we can find. So there
is no server
side installation of Velero, which is to be
expected because we haven't done that yet.
We're going to use the client CLI
to to
to do that.
Okay.
So
we just need to configure.
So you need to The secret. Pass the
so so we you need to have the
the AWI
the menu credentials
in a file
or pass it as
a I think if you pass it as
an environment variable, it would work.
And we'll just But I think it's that
file. It seems to be quite simple. So
menu dot creds.
And mains was
menu admin,
menu admin.
That should be that taken care of.
Do we need to
oh, that's the manual deployment. So we can
just ignore that.
And I guess what we want is this
here.
Yes. So just the
plugin version is going to be version one
point
point two point zero. So you might wanna
paste that into a a text editor so
you can edit that stuff.
Yeah. The secret file needs to point to
to that secret file you just created.
Okey dokey.
Just all my automation from spinning up the
cluster. We can get rid of that.
Velero install
and paste. Okay.
We're gonna Alright. So line three.
Yes. And
bucket name?
Should probably create a bucket. Right?
So let's just grab the IP address for
this. This is our
cluster.
And I just log in with those credentials.
I'll just quickly create one.
Yep,
new bucket.
There we go.
I'll call it Velero. And now we have
the bucket name.
So,
oh, good. That's what that's what's there too.
I called this Velero.creds.
Use volume snapshots false.
What's Yeah. It's gonna be false because
with
let's say
Okay.
Okay. So so that's okay. So so let's
let's take a pause. Yeah.
So so far, we have configured
the storage with we're looking at the storage
where the backups are going to go to.
So when we if if and when we
need a restore,
we'll pull from that storage. Mhmm. The other
part of of the of the Velero configuration
is
persistent storage.
So without the persistent storage piece,
we can back up and restore all day
long all of the Kubernetes objects.
Now if you have persistent data
anywhere that you also want to back up,
then you have to set up something another
piece,
which is the,
the volume snapshots.
Now be if you were using
one of the providers
for which we we have a plug in,
so we the Velero team maintains plug ins
for AWS,
GCP,
Azure,
and we also there is also a team
at VMware that that maintains
the vSphere plug in.
And there are a bunch of there are
some plug ins for other
persistent storage.
Yes. So we we just have to go
in documentation and see
what's listed there.
Now if you'd if you're not using any
of those providers, if you are, we recommend
you use this specific plug in because it's
going to be better.
You can use Rustic.
Rustic is also an open source tool.
It's a tool that it's integrated in Velero,
and we use it to do to,
do a file system level backup of that
persistent storage.
So with the plug in from a provider,
we don't do that. What we do is
we call the provider's API,
and we trigger snapshots.
So we just say, you know, okay. The
user wants a backup of this persistent storage.
Take a snapshot. Take a snapshot.
Right. And the information gets stored in the
metadata.
So we know the ID, and we know
where to fetch it from when we when
we wanna do a restore. We do the
same thing in reverse. We just we access
the provider's API and say, okay. Give me
this this snapshot.
Alright. So
so if we don't have the that plug
in, so we use Rustic. And now we
have to look at the documentation for how
to install
Rustic
with Velero. And by the way, just so
people know,
if you run the Velero install against let's
say you configure one way and you want
to update the configuration,
you just run the Velero install again
in that whatever it's there is going to
update everything.
Okay.
Just just in case, for example, if we
run the install, oh, we forgot to install
REST, like, we could run it again with
the REST command.
So let's go and, in on the documentation
and see what I would do is
just open a new
new tab there
and search
for REST.
Yes. That the first one.
Okay. So we have to
Okay.
So
oh, yeah. I could just do the new
version. Flag.
Alright.
Yeah. We we so we set the use
volume snapshots to false because we're not going
to have
Velero calling any provider's API. So that's just
that's just it creates
less
CRDs,
less resources related to Velero that we we
wouldn't need anyway.
Okay. So you have the s three URL
set up to your correct IP. Right? The
145.40.c.
Okay.
You typed very fast, so I didn't see
you updating that.
And
I think that's it.
I I don't know.
Alright. Let's do it. I mean, it's fake
confidence. But, mean, let's do it. Yeah. You're
right. So Velero installed provider AWS because we're
using our s c compatible API.
We've got a bucket name. We're using Rustic
because we don't have
the snapshot API provider support, and we've got
that set to false here. That all makes
sense. We pass in our API credits here
for menu, and then we connect the dot
here.
So I will just quickly
run this here.
Is it gonna use my
kube config environment variable to speak to the
right cluster? I guess so.
We'll find that. I
just Sorry. Say that again? I'm assuming it's
just gonna use my default context for
Oh, okay. Great
thing to mention.
There is a global flag that you can
use to point to a specific context
if it's not the one you're on.
But if you don't use that flag, it's
going to install on the context you're on.
Okay. I'm I'm okay with that. I've got
my context set to there. We also got
a comments in great tip.
Raverley UK has been uninstalling and reinstalling the
Velero
change of config. So there we go.
Oh, my file name must be
wrong.
Minion. Minion crudes?
How did I manage that? Minion crudes.
I must have been in salt stack mode
there. I have no idea. Maybe you're hungry
for a filet mignon.
Perhaps.
Yeah.
Okay.
It looks like it has deployed
everything we need to our
cluster.
Do you want me to run the logs
command to make sure that looks I
think yeah. Let's show it. You didn't catch
the last o. Okay.
I see no errors. So
our confidence was just we have installed Velero
to our cluster.
Does this just get installed and not the
default namespace then? Velero
namespace.
So it installs by default on the Velero
namespace. If you do wanna install it in
this
namespace a custom namespace, you can also do
that. We have documentation for that.
Okay. Awesome.
No left as a comment saying bananas. Obviously,
has been watching the minions movie recently. So
I do love those movies myself. I'm a
sucker for them. Yep. I do too. I
love it.
They're so cute. Oh, yeah. Definitely.
My daughter's only two and a half, but
I'm waiting for her just to get to
that age where she starts to pay more
attention for longer periods of time so I
can just like watch all the minions movies
all the time.
Okay.
So Velero and Rustic appear to be running.
They appear to be happy.
Is that it? Stream done. We're finished. Right?
It just works. That's it. That's it.
So we could try creating the backup.
Okay.
I'll Do want me to tell you the
command or you wanna
show the docs?
Yeah. Well, I'll I'll pull up the docs,
but we can we can definitely just
feel brave.
I'm assuming if I just type dash help,
I may get a little bit of guidance
as well. Yes. Yes.
Okay. So we got Velero backup command.
Oh, we got a bunch Sorry.
So before we do a backup, let's look
at that backup location.
Do a Velero
get
backup
dash location.
Alright. So
so that
backup location,
if you're not familiar with Velero, you're going
to be wondering where did I with where
did that get came from?
So when we did the install,
we passed some parameters.
For example,
a dub use the AWS
plug in. And the so the Velero the
way Velero works is
for each
storage location
where you want to install
the sorry. For each,
storage location where you want to install, not
install, but upload the backups to,
you need to have a corresponding
backup location.
That is sort of, like, the abstraction that
Velero uses
to to add configuration
for the storage location.
So everything that Velero needs to know to
make that connection.
If
you don't
create it ahead of time, if you don't
pass a specific flags or installation,
Velero is going to give you a little
hand and create a default
backup storage backup the the name is the
full name is backup storage location.
In the CLI, it's backup dash location, but
it's the same thing.
So we'll create
one for you that's named default
that's going to be using the parameters that
you passed in during the install. So we
we knew you were using the AWS plug
in.
So that backup location
in in the s s
three URL, that little flag
I might got might have gotten that wrong.
So all of so that's part of the
configuration.
You can look at the CRDs
that got the the CRs
that get created,
if you're interested.
So at any rate,
this is a very good command that I
I really like this command,
that gives us the the information if the
location is available or not. This is the
very first thing when I do support. That's
the first thing I wanna know.
Is your backup location connected and up and
running?
Because if it is a new you're not
gonna be able to upload
backups or download backups or restore backups.
So that's up and running. Great. You can
also use that command to create new ones.
You can delete it,
and there is always
one that will be the default one. And
what that means is when you are creating
backups and you don't specify
a backup location,
Velero will use the default.
But if you have, let's say, three or
what however many,
you can pass to the backup commands
the specific backup location name to use for
that backup. Same thing with the restore. Wherever
you wanna restore from, if you don't specify,
Velero will use the default one.
And and and, again, I I love that
command that just lets you know everything is
up and running.
And if not, then then we dig through
the logs and see what's going on.
Okay.
Awesome. There's
a a lot to unpack there. I've got
a a couple of questions. So
we can have multiple bucket locations.
So we could, in theory, be
backing up to AWS s three and Google's
own cloud storage thing. Is that something I
would have, like, one backup go to multiple
locations?
Is that a common pattern, or would it
be that different backups go to different locations?
Absolutely.
So you have to set up one location,
like, at least one location for each of
those providers if you want to send
back up to different providers. It's it's definitely
a good strategy
as as a means of back backing up
your backups. Or maybe you just want to
that's
I don't know if people do that, but
you might wanna have a section of your
cluster guru, just
GCP or another section not some namespace go
to AWS.
Yeah. In other words,
flexibility.
So
so one thing to point out is for
people who is familiar with Velero,
up to 1.5,
you could have that, but Velero only accepted
one
secret
key value pair.
So if you wanted to switch from one
provider to another provider, you had to manually
update
the Kubernetes secrets
to the secret you're using
because Velero could only handle one secret.
I mean yes.
So with with version 1.6,
actually, that is the the the main feature
we added.
And there is a blog post also that
talks about it, and there is documentation that
talks about it in drum drum roll. I
never start with the end. The
feature is you can have you can now
have multiple
secrets
with Velero.
So you can definitely
you just create you have let's say you
create the secrets
on Kubernetes.
Let's say you create five secrets. Mhmm. And
when you create
the the backup storage location,
you can pass in a name of the
secrets you want to associate with the backup
storage location. So now you can have a
secret for AWS,
a secret for GCP,
and you can just tell Velero, hey. This
is the secret for this location
that that and use that.
So that's pretty neat.
Yeah.
Very interesting. Definitely.
So the other thing that's jumped out to
me here is that,
you know, I did an API resources, and
I just kind of grabbed it down to
the Velero stuff, is that everything that we're
working with can just be configured through a
custom resource. Which means I can get ops
all of my backup and restore processes as
well. Is is that right?
I am forgetting now
what the glitch would be, but Velero has
some
some hooks there that
even it will not recognize some stuff, and
I'm forgetting what the stuff is. Mhmm.
Because we do an automatic
we keep reconciling
to check the
if there is new backups to to be
uploaded, for example.
I think if you create a backup
just
manually, let's say, or with GitOps bypassing the
Velero CLI,
I there is something that I'm not remembering.
I have to ask my teammates that Velero
will not recognize and Right.
Get you in trouble. Okay. Noted. Okay. We
got two comments there that should quickly tackle
before we we kinda progress there. So Noel
is saying that he spotted the Velero bug
command and is just saying kudos. That's awesome
feature.
I never Yeah. Thank you. Never noticed that,
but
oh, yeah. Yeah. Thank you for for we
love knowing what people love. For
version 1.7,
we have planned to do
a Velero
diagnosis tool. It might be called Velero crash
or something
that
it's a bit tricky because, if you run
that and it's going to output things from
your cluster, it it needs to be
nothing that they'll be private. So we we're
going to be
very careful about that. But, basically, you run
that. You output if you need if you
have a problem with Velero, if you're asking
for support or if you just wanted to
troubleshoot it yourself, You run that. It will
give you all of the,
all all the information you have to look
at, like, the the proper logs, all the
proper things that will be relevant.
Anyway,
I'm just saying we're always looking for to
to make things easier for for people to
to see what's going on. Awesome.
Okay. We'll tackle one more, and then we'll
we'll continue. But Nils is asking, can Velero
back up etcd?
Yeah. Yep. Yep. That's a every
Kubernetes resource
gets backed up by Velero.
Awesome.
Alright. Everything from etcd.
Yeah. Which is which is great because, you
know, we wanna be able to restore everything
from the ground up if the worst were
to ever happen. It makes a lot of
sense. So so one thing that may be
useful for people to know, people who are
not familiar with Velero is
Velero
only accesses
the through
the server API.
So,
we're not taking the file system backup of.
There are tools that do that if and
you can use that in parallel with Velero
too.
But Velero only uses the API,
and,
that is what makes it be able to
do, for example, selective backups because with the
API,
we have we we can exclude things,
and there's a lot more flexibility.
So just so so people are clear, we're
not doing a file system backup of the
entire SCD.
We're just backing
up the the the objects in the database.
Okay. Awesome.
So I guess our next step here would
be to create our first backup.
Yeah. Let's do it.
Alright. So I did see there was a
Velero backup command. So I'll just
Oh, one neat thing or maybe maddening, depends
on how your brain works, is with
all Velero commands,
except I think for the downloads, you can
interchange the command. So you can do create
backup or backup create, and either one will
work.
I actually did an entire episode where I
tried to build a kube control plugin to
override the Kubernetes verb noun behavior because I
really disapprove of it. So I'm glad that
I could just take backup create rather than
create backup in it.
But I guess personal preference.
I like I like starting with the verb,
so I stick to that so I don't
have to think, wait. What am I writing?
Okay.
I'll I'll I'll do it your way. So
you would do create
backup?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And give it a name.
Okay.
So backup
one. Oh, back one one.
Okay. And then I need to do dash
help on this to see if I need
other flags, or is that gonna do something
for me out of the box?
That's it. That's how you need it. I
mean, again, if you wanted to specify
backup storage location to to save it to
that wasn't the default, then you add the
flag there.
If you wanted to
Sorry. I knew. Yeah.
So that's just gonna back up everything? Like,
that's just the default behavior except everything. Yes.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. And that a good that's
a good point. If you wanted to do
a selective backup, then there are flags you
can use.
Backup. Alright.
It's not done. Not done. Okay. Sorry.
So what is done here is the request
for the backup to
for the backup operation.
So Got it. You can do
yeah. Velero describe or you can do Velero
get backup.
Backup or backups, that's another thing. Single or
plural doesn't matter.
I have backup one.
Yeah.
So is this just a a wrapper on
the Kube control? I mean, it's it's just
going to the Kubernetes API and and request
in resources. Is is that correct? Yeah. We
are now wrapping the Kube control tool.
We we have we we are doing our
own API calls. Okay. But, yeah, it's only
going against the server
in in getting that re Velero
CR
that
gets created with each backup. There is a
CR that gets created,
and that gets updated by the reconciling
things that happen. And, so what we what
we are doing is
getting information from from that resource.
Okay. Oh, yeah. So I can actually see
here that
it looks like I can just describe my
backup
backup one, and I'm probably gonna get, yeah,
very similar information. Not displayed quite as nice,
but very similar.
Okay. Let's go back to the Velero
command.
First thing that jumps out to me here
was first is completed, which is great, but
also there's an a default expiration on my
backup. So it's, like, twenty nine days.
Yes.
Yes. So you can set that TTL.
Some people have asked if can you set
it forever?
No.
We don't have that ability right now, but
some people have asked, can you just, like,
make it not expire, basically?
But, otherwise,
you can override the thirty day default and
set your own expiration.
Yeah. I guess the forever would be essentially
an anti part because you don't wanna take
one backup and then say keep it forever.
I'm assuming we want this scheduled to run-in
a regular interval and expire the older backups
as we progress through time. So I can
understand
that constraint. Yeah.
Okay. And
I guess this also means that you shouldn't
schedule your backups around once every twenty nine
days just to create a new one. That's
probably not ideal either.
Is there a a cadence that you would
recommend? Is it is it daily? Is it
hourly? Does it depend on the workload? Like,
what what would you do in your own
clusters?
To be completely transparent,
I am not running clusters in production. Right.
Got it. And even if I were, I'll
be I'll be cautious about
saying
I don't know. I think you need more
data points than one.
It's definitely very good to be asking what's
the best practice, but I think
it would vary.
Just as an engineer, I would say it
varies it would vary.
It should vary depending on what is it
that you that you're backing up.
Is it is it programmer
stuff? Is is it production?
Yeah.
That's a that's a great part. My question
was extremely naive, but you're right. Like, it
depends on the workloads on the cluster. Right?
Like, there are some applications.
I mean, maybe Kafka would be an example
that does its own replication, so you could
maybe back it up at a slightly lesser
velocity than maybe something else that doesn't.
There are too many ifs, buts, whens, and
maybes there. So the let's just straight that
question from all records. The question is not
naive at all. You is a very pertinent
question that everybody should be asking because you
also don't want to
be backing up and thinking
of, okay. This is data that's
being transmitted up to the cloud,
being stored.
You pay for all of that. So you
have to think about it. So it's not
naive at all. It's just that it's it's,
going to depend on things that I have
no idea how to how to, help you
with.
Okay.
So,
I mean, I'm amazed at how easy this
has been so far. We have installed Velero.
It's already made a backup. I'm assuming if
I just jump over to our menu
and hit refresh,
we have our backup one directory.
We've got
a whole bunch of stuff in here.
We've got the CSI volume snapshots.
We've got volume backups, resource lists.
I guess this is just all the different
components of my cluster backed up individually.
Does that mean I can restore these
isolated or
or as everything at once that that I
have that option and flexibility?
Alright. So
if you go back to the command line,
I wanna show you one feature, and then
I'll answer your question. So you
can run a Velero,
Downloads.
I forgot the flag.
I think it's download backup and then the
name of the backup.
Could I could be wrong. Yeah.
Let's look at the help, please. Download help.
Oh, I think this was done. It's a
non command download.
Oh, that's okay. So Velero backup I'm sorry.
Velero backup, that's the one that doesn't have
the
the switch.
The little backup downloads
in the name of the backup.
There we go. Yeah. Alright. So that downloads
the whole thing to your local machine,
and then you can untie and explore the
contents.
Now to ask your quest to answer the
question you asked,
yes, you can
selectively
restore.
So one back best practice for backups in
general is to have at least one periodic
backup that you're backing up everything.
If you can, some some some organizations
are going to have restrictions. They're not gonna
want
some
people backing up some namespace.
But
as long as everything gets backed up one
way or another. But so, ideally, you have
a backup for everything.
And then when you it's time to restore,
you can decide what it is that you
want to restore.
And then you can say, okay. I just
wanna restore
particular namespace, for example.
Okay.
So,
I mean, there's no point in us restoring
this to our cluster. Right? We should probably
cause a little bit of chaos into something.
Although, I think I've all I think I've
just identified a mistake that I've maybe made
during the setup is that I don't think
we can actually delete the default namespace. Should
I deploy my fake stateful workload to a
new namespace?
Or can I delete the default names? I
don't think I've ever attempted that before. What
what you can do is
maybe
do you have a the workload installed in
that cluster?
Excuse me. I do. Yeah. So we got
a time writer, which is every ten seconds
raising the time to fail on a persistent
volume.
Okay. So you can delete that.
I mean, if you I suppose that is
a
it's not a high value thing.
No.
Yeah. I mean, Velero is robust enough.
It's just like in a demo
situation.
I I don't wanna be troubleshooting your production
cluster.
No. This is an entirely contrived cluster. So
let me share with the viewers what I
I've put in place just to kind of
demonstrate what we're doing. So this is just
a really simple bash script,
but it does have a persistent volume.
And then the persistent volume, we're writing
the time every ten seconds to it. So
if I just run a WC dash L,
you know, this has been running all day.
We got nearly 2,000 time entries and our
PVC. So
I guess what I would like to see
now is that if I delete the persistent
volume and the time rate or stateful set
is that we can actually restore those almost
2,000 entries into our cluster as if nothing
happened. Is that
Hold on. Because I I am forgetting now
if with Rustic, need to specify something during
the backup. Uh-huh. Okay. So let me just
Do you want me to open up the
backup and and poke around a little bit?
Or
Either that or we could look at the
docs.
Yeah. Maybe we should look at the docs.
That's
what that's what people other people would do.
So I'd rather I I think I'm just
the the silly one that would go the
harder. I think the docs is better. Yeah.
Agreed.
We might have to create another backup if
I think there is something special we need
to do.
Okay. Alright. So the installation requires the use
rustic flag. We did that. Mhmm.
Okay. To back up.
Yes. That section.
This is just creating a sample workload of
a PVC. It looks like do we need
a annotation on it?
Yeah.
Oh, no. That's an it's an No. So
Oh, okay. Yeah. That's an We we can
use the I think I always get those
two confused. I think what we want is
the opt in.
Using opt in pod volume backup.
You only have one volume one pod to
backup, right, that has to persist the bot
better?
Yeah.
And it looks like there's a flag here.
Is that important? Default volumes to Rustic,
or is that something else?
Default volumes. I don't know what default volumes
to rustic means.
Hold on. I mean, let
me also read this.
Backup
create
dash help.
Let's just see what it says here.
Okay. So it defaults I think true. And
So
Yeah. I think it I think it has
backed up.
Because
the rest default volumes to Rustic is the
default of true, and it seems to suggest
that it will use Rustic by default. It
should be it should be out of yeah.
It's not a production workload. I'm okay if
I lose my 2,000 timestamps. I'd be a
little upset, of course, but I will go
over it.
Do you wanna look at the content of
the backup, see if there's Rustic stuff in
there?
Yeah. Let's do that. So let's just move
this to this directory
and then load it.
Got a whole bunch of stuff.
Faint
finder. No. Open.
Yeah. That works. Okay.
So
I'm assuming
would be under resources,
persistent volumes.
Got a JSON fail.
I think there should be a Rustic folder.
I don't Rustic folder. Use Rustic all the
time. And and when I do use it,
I forget what is what should be there.
There's no Rustic folder?
Above resources?
We've got a metadata.
Yeah. I don't know. I mean, we oh,
there's a that's our claim.
Maybe we don't have the actual data. I
mean, I could always, I guess, just the
prep
for
I can't remember the format of my timestamps
now.
Oh, I used the date command. So
I searched for April.
I don't think we may be I don't
think there's any data. I don't yeah. I
think the there will be a folder with
Rustic. Let's do the opt in.
Like, from the
documentation,
let's go in the opt in and run
the cube cuddle,
the number one. Yep. So I notate the
pods.
Okay. Let's do that. So if I do
get pods
yep. Still work. We've got a cube control
command here. We're in a default namespace.
I guess I could just annotate
stateful set time
writer
and we're adding,
we just have a PVC volume.
So I think,
yeah. We're adding an annotation here. This is
backup PVC
volume.
Done.
Okay. So
So now we create See number yeah. See
the yeah.
Create the backup.
So number two, create a backup, and then
we can look at the just the
backup describe command
to see if there is rustic stuff in
there.
Okay. So it's still backing up.
I mean, it's taking a bit longer, I
guess.
I think it's, yeah, it's finished. Okay.
Okay, so it looks like we can use
the customer resource.
Get what was it? Pod volume backup.
Try all. Pod volume. Pod volume.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I annotated the state full set, but
I haven't restarted the pod. So
I probably set this up to fail there
because if I describe the pod,
we're actually probably not gonna have the annotation.
Yeah.
So I should probably just annotate that part
rather than doing the stateful set.
Yeah.
But I'm learning, which is important.
Okay. Let's create backup three,
and we'll scrape
scrape
three.
Okay.
Gives that a few seconds to finish. It
seems like it's only taken around,
I think, ten seconds last time to back
up the
So so the very Velero create backup or
backup create has a flag wait, dash dash
wait, if you want to use that. Ah,
nice. So it will run we would only
return after the backup's created, and you can
also control c out of that.
Just FYI.
Ah, nice.
Okay. I'm not
seeing anything for the pod volumes back up.
Of course, that doesn't mean that it hasn't
backed it up. But based on what I
see in the docs here,
I kind of expected maybe to see something
there.
Should I download it again, do you think?
Did you run that cube cube control
bits to see the label for the backup?
I
can run it again.
Our backup name was
backup three.
Yeah. So we're getting an empty list back.
And I'll just describe the pod and make
sure I didn't mess up either.
Oh, that's not a Okay.
Okay. I think I'm working because I'm doing
this the hard way and not actually reading
the documentation.
I don't think this is the type of
volume. Is it maybe the name of the
volume? Is that something I think it's the
name. Yeah. Yeah.
But that's just me being rather shitty again.
Okay.
So what was our volume actually called? It's
called data.
So I would just re annotate.
Fourth time's a charm.
Fourth time's a charm. Not who said third
time's a
charm?
Exactly.
Overwrite.
We are innovating.
Okay. Back up. Let's go to work this
thing.
Four.
Oh, no. I should've done all good. I'm
glad I got that command wrong because I
wanna do the wait flag
dash dash.
Cool.
So I guess now that I've got the
annotation correct,
the backup volumes annotation takes the list of
the PVCs that we want to opt and
to backup, which makes much more sense than
my random just backup all PVCs.
Let let's run the cube control
bit for the label, see if it's what
shows up.
Okay. So that was
this command
here. Only my backup's got a new name.
Look at that.
When you do it right, it works. Awesome.
Okay. So now let's
download it and see
the structure.
The rustic data should be there.
Yep.
Thank you, River DK who's very thankful that
I don't prerecord my terminal stuff. No, I
do everything very live to my own success
and detriment depending on how my day is
going.
So
I just created folders with wacky names. Now
we now have b k four and then
now hungry for a burger king, but
we'll jump in here,
extract this,
and we're hoping
we'll see under resources
something called Rustic.
Yes.
There we go. Yeah. Don't know.
It's a JSON file.
I I don't know if we should be
seeing a JSON file or not a JSON
file. I'm I'm I'm not entirely sure. You
said it's not a file level backup. Right?
So
JSON may be may be embedded there.
However it works, I'm not entirely sure. But
I think I think that that rustic folder
is a good good sign.
Yeah. I'm I'm feeling And
it would these were labeled properly,
so I think you can go ahead and
crash your workloads.
Okay. So I'm a silly Kubernetes operator
who comes along and says, hey, that stateful
set doesn't look useful.
And delete.
Oh, I'm in the wrong directory.
And I need my kube configs. Let's try
that one more time.
Time writer.
Because I'm having a very bad day, I
haven't just deleted my stateful set. I am
going to delete
my persistent volumes
too.
So, we'll delete the claim first.
Oh, I delete the volume first. Oh, and
it should still work.
Completely claim too. Maybe speed that up.
And we'll run get.
Okay. We have deleted the stateful set. We
have deleted the claim and the volume. That
2,000 lines of very useful timestamps has now
disappeared forever.
But I guess we wanna restore
our no broken production service.
Yeah. Okay.
I'm gonna just go out and I'll let
you know because the CLI has been so
easy to work with that I could probably
just do restore backup backup four.
Is that what you want me to do?
No. No. Almost.
Almost.
It's Velero restore
dash dash from
dash sorry. No. No. No. Backup.
From dash
backup
and then the name of the backup.
Oh, no. Yeah. I guess that works.
I never put the equal, but that should
work.
Almost.
No. Wait.
What?
Maybe it's the equal
sign. It looks like it wants us to
do a Velero restore
Oh, I'm sorry. Gosh.
Yeah.
It's a
create. Yeah. So you wanna create
a restore.
I intuitively,
I do the same. I think, oh, we
I wanna restore. What what I wanna do
is restore, so I the command should be
named restore. But you wanna create
because, basically, with all the little commands,
you're not
actually creating anything.
Things get created or updated through the reconciliation.
All that we can do is create a
request
to the API server. So we want to
create a restore
request
from the backup, and that's gonna be that
request is going to be sent,
and then things will be done
Okay. Magically.
So let's kick that off then, and then
we'll tackle a couple of the the comments
that we've received. Yeah. Let's start it. Okay.
So
Noah was just again, reiterating that the CLI
user experience is really nice. He's very happy
with that. Oh, did that not pop up?
There we go.
We got a comment from Hector Gibson who
suggested
that I run the rep rep again and
the backup data just to see if it's
there. Yeah. I think that's a good idea.
Let's see.
Because Noel actually posted another comment, which I'll
get to in a second, but
yeah.
So it
doesn't look like the data is in the
backup that we download,
but someone has suggested that perhaps the JSON
file just contains a pointer to something that's
in the SD object store.
But I guess that we could poke around
menu if we if we wanted to.
I'm assuming. So you can also do Velero
restore to see the status.
Velero restore get.
K.
Just that. Just
well, you could've could've passed the name.
So it's in progress still.
Yeah. Because we didn't do
selective restore of our broken or mess in
the service. We're we're restoring everything in the
cluster. Is that correct?
Mhmm. Okay.
Does that have any
is this safe to do in a live
production cluster or would it be something that
you you maybe take it offline and restore
before doing that?
Because I'm assuming it's modifying
HCD and doing a whole bunch of stuff
there. I'm just
curious.
I don't know how to I don't know
the answer to that question. I think I
think the answer is a safe yes.
If you some when you do when you're
working with databases,
you want to do the
sometimes you wanna do a what is it
called, FS freeze
back
up. Mhmm.
And after you have the backup, you want
I
think it's called FS unfreeze.
And when you do a restore, you might
have to do the same thing. I'm forgetting.
Yeah.
Just f s unfree freeze, restore,
or otherwise,
you should be good to go.
Yeah. I I'm sure there's
stuff in the documentation that I'm just not
reading, but it looks like our backup has
restored successfully.
So does that mean in theory, if I
run get pods, we should see that our
stateful set is
back with it was before.
Should be. Look at that.
And it's up and running
like magic.
I do like magic.
And we now have over 2,000 entries. That's
awesome. Really,
really simple to just get that running, do
a backup, and the restore.
That's exactly what we wanna see.
So,
let's have a look just quickly.
There's all my
broken backups, but there's a good one. Okay.
I was just curious if we have a
pod volume backup here. So I guess this
is the bit that's actually got my
data
bit.
Very cool. Yeah. Yeah.
Let's just check.
Yeah. Okay. I'm pretty happy with that.
That was good. We got a a question
from no.
Doesn't Kubernetes complain about applied revision of the
revision was updated after a backup and we
try and restore?
I have no idea.
Something I guess.
I don't know what a applied revision is.
Maybe it's something that I know by a
different name.
It's not something I am
confident in either to try and describe, but
I believe that when Kubernetes resources are modified
and the revision number goes back in time,
that it would complain that the update was
out of sync
and probably wouldn't take place. But I'm assuming
Velero just
handles these things for us.
Yes.
Something to experiment with. Do
you think he's talking about
group versions?
No? I'm not sure. Feel free to give
us a little bit more context, Noel, if
you want us to have a little bit
of a chat about it. And if anyone
else, of course, is watching and you have
any questions or wanna see something with Velero,
you know, now is the time to drop
in before we we finish up for this
session.
Okay.
Is there anything you would like us to
take a look at before we finish this
session, or do you think that we've covered
enough of the the capabilities of of what
we wanna use Velero for?
I think
that is the bread and butter restoring.
And then for anything besides that, what I
would recommend is going through the docs
and,
to figure out, for example, how do you
do
how to include and exclude things. We have
a page for that.
You can schedule backups, so you can just
you just continuously be
creating backups for you based on what you
specify.
What else?
There is a page for
contributing.
It feels always welcome. Right?
Oh, absolutely.
There is
a GitHub
discussion
where people can drop questions,
and everybody
is,
we try to answer. Anyone is is welcome
to try to answer questions.
We do have a okay. This is not
what you asked, but I'm jumping ahead. You
asked if I there is something related
to the Velero tool that we should look
at.
You know, Velero is not complicated to use.
That's that's about it.
Yeah. I'm I'm really happy with how simple
using the CLI was to get started. I
like that it takes care of all of
that, you know, essentially toil of actually installing
it to my cluster. I didn't need to
go find a Helm chart or worry about
how to do that. It just kind of
it just worked.
And creating the backup restore, I mean, it's
just I love it when things are just
simple and it's just easy to use. It
makes my life easier, especially when there's something
as important as as backups and restoration.
We we we do want these difficult problems
to be handled by the tooling. And I
think Velero's doing a great job at that.
So
I think I mean, the only comments we're
getting right now are a little bit of
discussion about my terrible audio quality in previous
episodes. So thank you for reminding everybody there.
Yeah. And there's a resource page on the
Velero.
Website where you can find ways to,
con like, get in touch with the team,
and,
there is a community meeting every Tuesday,
9AM Pacific time.
Everybody's free to attend and also drop
any discussion topic on our HackMD file that's
it's all linked on that page.
Awesome. Alright. Let me pop us back and
we will.
There we go.
So Velero
handles backups and restores. We've seen how easy
installation was. We've created backups and we restored.
All you need is a SD compatible
storage location or API.
You've seen how easy it was to get
manual there. I should have came prepared with
that setup, but we got there in the
end.
I really I I think I went off
the page there a bit too early, but
I love the schedule command. It just took
cron syntax. I'm excited to start deploying Velero
to my clusters now and taking
advantage of this. I just wanna say thank
you for joining me today. It was a
pleasure to kinda go through this and get
your insights into Velero.
The 1.6 release seems to be really, really
cool. I'm glad that that is out and
shipped.
Is there anything you'd like to share about
what's coming next in Velero before we finish
up?
Oh my gosh.
Blank.
We are going to do some
so
there is a set of tooling that's sort
of new. It's called Carvel.
It has some
Carvel. Yeah. So y y t and
KDB,
and
it's it's basically for deploying,
building images,
templating,
and we're going to be compatible with that.
And the why I'm saying that first is
because I'm going to be doing that work.
I'm just not remembering what else is. So
it's on for version 1.7,
but maybe we should have looked at so
at the very root of our repository on
GitHub, there is a road map dot m
d file.
And now that I'm reading it
yeah, so we're going to integrate we're going
to make artifacts available so people who use
those tools can install Velero, deploy Velero
using those tools.
And
we continuous working we are continuing work
to do
e two e test
test for Velero, which is awesome. We're going
to do the the
diagnostic
tool that I mentioned.
That's gonna be
great to have.
The c so we have CSI a CSI
plugin
for snapshots,
and we're going to bring it to general
availability.
We are going to do plug in versioning
Okay. Which is we don't have versioning right
now for the plug ins. Yeah. I p
v six support.
I know the upload progress monitoring is on
desired items, but I think it's going to
be implemented for 1.7.
Yeah. That's what's on the list. Those are
the big ticket items.
Again, a quite a a number of of
items there. So, you know, people that are
watching or their interest has peaked in Velero,
go and check out the repository. Hopefully, you
can start contributing to a really cool project.
Alright. Thanks. And yes. Okay. No. No. Go.
Please. I I I No. We have an
integration with the tilts.
Some people might not know tilt, but there
is instruction in to set it up, and
it is ridiculously
easy.
If you if you wanna run Velero codes,
that's where I suggest you start. Even even
I've been working with Velero for years, and
that's what I use because it's the easiest
and it's faster faster than anything else.
Well, personally, I do have go around. I
I do have previous videos with the tilt
team and the carvel team. And strangely enough,
Carvel video is probably one of the worst
audio recordings on my side that I've ever
done. So anyone that does watch that, the
demo is very cool of Carvel. I just
Oh, I'm gonna watch it today because I
I am I have to learn.
No. It was great session. I learned a
lot. The Carvel tool was is really, really
interesting. So
alright. Thank you again for joining me today.
I hope you have a a really good
day and a great week, and I will
see you again soon. Thank you for joining
me today. Same to you, and thank you
so much, David. Thank you. Bye bye. Alright.
Bye.